ذهب مؤخرا رواد ومحبي تطبيق التيك توك
مقطع لداع يا صومالي وادم عبد الرحمن
المقطع لم يتجاوز دقيقه ونصف لكن هذا
المده الزمنيه القصيره جدا ابدع فيها
انصار الداعيه او خلايا التنظيمات
الاصوليه الاسلاميه الالكترونيه
باستخدام كل انواع والوان المونتاج معها
يطلق عليه تصدر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بعناوين مختلفه منها الشيخ ادم الصومالي
الذي ارعب جميع مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وايضا مشهور التيك توك صاحب العيون كره
الرصاصها في المشهد المذكور كان ادم
الصومالي يقف على منبره ويرتدي ثوبا عربيه
وعلى راسها شيء يشبه الشماغ وبخلاف ما هو
متوقع لم يتم اي محتوى من خطبته الماضيه
ولكن الحق دراميه كانت في التقاط نظره لا
تم تحريرها وصناعتها بفلات روشات
لتظهر وكانها محاكاه لشخصيه خرجت من عصر
الفايكنج او محارب اسطوري يقذف من عينيه
اشعه ليزر المعلومات المتوفره عن شيخ
التيك توك هذا والنجم الصاعد الجديد في
اوساط الجماعات الاصوليه قليله منها انه
احد شيوخ حركه الشباب الصوماليه المسلحه
المتطرفه نشطه في عمليه التجنيد لصالح
تنظيم القاعده وحكم عليه بالسجن عده مرات
على خلفيه داعمه للجماعات الاسلاميه
الراديكاليه المسلحه كان مقربا من امير
حركه الشباب احمد عبد الجدني قبل مقتل في
غار جويه امريكيه عام 2014
هربت داعي الراديكالي ادم الصومالي الى
جنوب الصومال مواقع سيطره حركه الشباب بعد
ان تم الافراج عن مؤخرا بكفاله من احد
السجون الصوماليه ليعلنا مباشره عن
انضمامه وبشكر رسمي الى حركه الشباب عبر
اذاعه بي بي سي سوماريا احتفال الحسابات
الالكترونيه الاصوليه بنجمها الجديد جاء
بالتزامن مع تصاعد وتيره اعمال العنف من
اختيالات وتفجيرات في عدد من المدن
الصوماليه ومنها العاصمه مقديشو كان من
بين ذلك اغتيال الشيخ عبد الناصر حاج احمد
احد رجال الدين البارزين في الصومال بعد
زرع عبوه ناسفه في سيارته وتم توجيه اصابع
الاتهام فيها الى الداعيه الاصول ادم عبد
الرحمن
فمن هو شيخ التيك توك الصومالي وما حكايته
ولماذا تم تصديرها في الساحه السلفيه
الجهاديه في هذا الوقت تحديدا وهل احتفاء
حركه الشباب ذراع تنظيم القاعده في
الصومال يعني تنصيب شيخ التيك توك اميرا
جديدا عليها ومواقع حركه الشباب اليوم في
الساحه الصوماليه انا هدى الصالح وهذا
برنامج جماعه معنا في حلقه اليوم ومن
العاصمه الصوماليه مقديشو الاستاذ عبد
الرحمن سالم الخبير والمختصار في شؤون
الجماعات الاسلاميه الراديكاليه حياك الله
معنا استاذ عبد الرحمن
حياكم الله مرحبا
اشكركم على هذه الاستضافه والاهتمام اللي
ما يجري في الصومال الله يسلمك استاذ عبد
الرحمن ابغى ابدا معك مين هو مشهور التيك
توك هذا اللي ظهر مؤخرا عنه واكتسح مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي تحديدا همم التيك توك
الشيخ همم عبد الرحمن
المعروس هذا سني
هو كان معروفا انه في اوساط
هرجيسا في شمال الاندلس حيث كان يمارس
الخطابته ونشر الدعوه في
العقدين الماضيين
واشترك هو واجه مع الاجهزه الامنيه الشرطه
اا بنشره ابكارا شاذه عن المجتمع بدعوته
الى حمل السلاح
بدوره في تجنيد الشباب وارساله الى الى
جنوب الصومالي وكذلك على علاقته السابقه
مع همم مع همم امين همم حركه الشباب
وبالتالي هو شخصيه اصبحت ااه ناره
اعتقاله
همم وخطاباته الناريه ثم بعد ذلك
همم في شهر مارس الماضي همم من هرجيسا الى
الى جنوب الصومال حيث وصل الى منطقه همم
منطقه جبل الوسطى وهي تقع في جنوب الصومال
حيث معقل الحركه ثم اعلن بعد ذلك انضمامه
الى الحركه ولاؤه لها وتمسكه بمباده
السابقه ودعوته الى مواصله القتال ضد
الدوله الصوماليه همم وتطبيق الشريعه
الاسلاميه
والمحاربه الكفار وهو طبعا كان يدور في
نهج وفي فلكلمات همم
المتشددها التي تتفرع عاده من تنظيم
القاعده وبالتالي فهو لم ياتي بشيء جديد
ولكنه همم
بخطاباته ناريه وبفصاحه باللغه الصوماليه
وباستخدام احيانا الشعري وكذلك الادب
الصومالي على طريقه
وزميله السابق احمد عبد الجودني هو على
شغله وهو الان في معقل الحركه
وفي صفوفها في جنوب الصومال طب هل هل كان
هو مثلا من الشخصيات اللي التحقت بمثلا في
افغانستان هل يعني تدرب في مواقع الصراع
مثل احمد جودني لان احمد قدني نفس الشيء
كان يعني تلقى تدريبات في افغانستان وهو
امير حركه همم الشباب في الصومال
في حركه الشباب
وتدريبه في معسكراتها في في جنوب الصومال
ولكنه كان مقيما في شهر جلسه ناشطا دعويه
في منشرا افكار ال- الحركه وما يرتبط بها
وكذلك همم احيانا همم نجد الامنيه
بانه يتولى اا بعض المعسكر يدرب بعض
الشباب في بعض المراكز وفي في في فيسه
وعلى هذا الاساس تم اعتقاله ولكنه ااه لم
يكن شخصيه صوره في اصحاحات القتال وفي
الساعات المعارك في جنوب الصومال وفي
غيرها كذلك بل اصبح ربما من الشخصيات التي
كانت تستخدم الوصايا الناعمه ورافدا من
روافد الروافد الحركه التي ومصنعا من
مصانعها همم حيث كان يعد ما تحتاجه الحركه
من رجال ثم يرسله اليه ربما كان يدور
وكذلك فيما يتعلق بالفتاوى وبالعلوم
الشرعيه التي تتلاقى مع النظام الحركه طب
هو نشاطه كان في هذه المنطقه الحاضر التي
ذكرتها ولا كان مثلا عنده انشطه عند مثلا
في الخطب في جوامع مختلفه يعني مدن مختلفه
في الصومال ام كان تمركز نشاطه في مدينه
واحده
قبل التحاقه الى الحركه همم يخطب في
المساجد كان احيانا كلمات في همم في
المنابر في الاعياد همم ولذلك همم كلما
كان يرتفع صوته ويدعو الى حمل السلاح
ومواجهه الحكومه همم كان يواجه بالاعتقال
ثم انه ايضا همم اعلن نقطه في غايه
الاهميه بنسبه له وهي اعدائه للنظام
الديمقراطي في سؤال الان وكذلك رفضه وجود
الهيئات الغربيه همم في ارجيسه التي كانت
تتعامل وتعاون مع مع حكومه الصناعي حيث
كانت ربما تقدم مساعدات تعليميه وانسانيه
وطبيه وما بين ذلك فكان يرى ان
صلاح تلك الهيئتي في سيرخيصه هي تؤدي الى
نفس الصليبيه والمسيحيه في سودان ينفل ذلك
وهو وهي من الاسباب الرئيسيه التي ادت الى
الاعتقالها مره ابغى اسالك استاذ عبد
الرحمن شو طب مثلا ان تم افراج عنا مؤخرا
لماذا همم طبعا همم افراده لم ياتي صدفه
هو تعرض لاعتقال لعده مرات همم وطبعا كما
تعرف المجتمع الصومالي والمجتمع قبلي همم
مجتمع مترابط
وكذلك ولهذا الاساس ربما استفاده من هذه
الناحيه اا انه لا يهدد ربما الحكومه او
انه
يراعي ويحفظ همم
اتفق عليه ولكنه يستفاد يعني لان همم
عندما هرب وتصلل من ثماني لم يكن لم تكن
تعرفه الاجهزه الامنيه ولهذا هو استفاد من
هذا الفراق همم ربما هو خدع [__] اهميه همم
وكان الذي امنيه تراقبه في بيته وكذلك في
تحركاته ولكنه همم اختار ان يلتحق الحركه
التي كان يؤمن بها
كان تحت الاقامه الجبريه لا لا لم تكن
هناك اقامه جب ولكنه ربما كانت همم بصوره
عامه كان مقيما في ارجيسه همم
وبالتالي هو اصلا كان من مؤيد الى حركه
بسرعه علنيه برغم همم احيانا ما كان يذكر
اسمها ولكنه بادبياته حديثه وما كان يدعو
اليه كان يتناقم ويلتحق
وينتفق مع ادبيات الحركه وبالتالي همم لم
تكن كانت جسده كان في ارجيسه ولكن كان
روحه وافكاره مع الحركه في جنوب الصومال
طب حضرتك يعني طبعا يعني متابع في داخل في
في همم في الساحه همم الصوماليه همم نشاطه
ديني والوعي مثلا في الجوامع في الخطب هل
لديه جمهور كبير من المصلين هل له رواد
اكثر
يعني شو طبيعه اللي انا صراحه يعني احنا
اللي اول مره يعني يظهر هذا الشخص لدى
الجمهور العربي يعني فكيف فجاه كده واصبح
نجم واحد مشاهير التيك توك لتروج لا
لتنظيمات المسلحه ربما ربما هذا يعود الى
استخدام الصوماليين وخاصه من فئه الشباب
مساله تيك توك مواقع التواصل اجتماعي
وعرضهم بعض اللقطات من همم من من من من من
من من من الحركه همم بغرض بغرض هجومه ورفض
افكارهم التي ينشرونها اضافه الى ان همم
حركتها كذلك تستخدم مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بصوره يوميه وكذلك عندما لا
يوجد هناك حاجب في الانترنت همم خاصه في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وفي تلغرام وما
الى ذلك فهذه تاتي في السياق اهتمام
الحركه همم باستخدامها الاعلام الذراع
الاعلامي للنشر افكارها همم
المسجد كذلك وقدماء المساجد كذلك مختلفون
لكن فيما يتعلق بهذا الشيخ والان انتقل
الى الى الى الى المناطق الخاضعه للسيارات
الحركه وليست له الان همم تحركات همم
كبيره
الشاشه طلعوا الحريات كبيره ممكن
يتنقل فيها في المرافق
ولكنه وهو يمارس نشاطه بحريه في داخل
الحركه
انتقال استاد عبد الرحمن كيف كان همم يعني
مدى الجمهور اللي كان ياتي للصلاه في
جامعه او في الجوامع الذي التي يتردد همم
اليها هذا كان كثيرا لان الشعب اصلا لا
يميزون بين هذا وذاك طالما ان الشيخ هو
يقيم في ارجيسه في المناطق الامينه همم
ويؤمن المصلين في المساجد يعني
فهنا لا تجد لا تجد هناك نقابه جميعا
يصلون في المساجد المساجد كلها مليئه وهمم
وكل من يقدم دروسا يجد انصار له يقدم
اليها وبالتالي كان له تاثيرا كبيرا في
اوصاد الشباب فيها اليسا في سؤال لان هذا
هذا هو الصعب الذي ايضا ادى الى اعتقاله
ومراقبته وكذا
ينشر تركها في قصائد الشعب في هذه هذه
مين عندك معلومات استاذ عبد الرحمن فين
حصلت تعليم الشرعي تعليم الفقهي شو
المستوى الديني اللي همم يعني همم
لديه لعبد الرحمن عبد الرحمن
ظاهره
كعالم كبير
ما اعرفه هو ان علومه الشرعيه التي يعتمد
عليها هو يتلقاها من المساجد من حلقات
المساجد وهي من اهم المدارس والمراكز
والمساجد التي تقدمها همم الحلقات الشرعيه
توجد في مدينه تاريخيه وفي سؤال
باعتبارها كانت امنه لم يحدث فيها اي
مشاكل لم تعرض الاهلي ذاته الامنيه
منذ 30 عاما ولهذا كثيرا الذين تلقوا
العلوم الشرعيه من المساجد ربما من
المراكز دائما ربما هم الذين يعترقون هذه
الافكار لانهم لم يجوا دراسات عميقه
وبحثيه ولم يتواصلوا يتلقوا من كذلك علماء
خارج الصومال ولهذا الاساس ربما التي نشا
فيها وترى فيها وتلقى فيها الدروس
من اسره منهم منظمين همم حركه الشباب
الصوماليه دعاء اخرين من نفس العائله من
عائلتها
ههه طبعا هذه المساله مرتبطه
باقتناع الشخص وانه ااه مؤمن لو معتقد بها
خاصه من يؤمن بالافكار
امكانيه المتطرفه ولكن كما ذكرت سابقا هذا
الشيخ هو صديقي لامير حركه الشباب
مرتبطه بما يؤمن بالشخص وما يدعو اليه وهي
ازمه كبيره
كان في بعض الانباء كانت تتكلم على ان همم
ادم الصومالي عندما خرج وهرب اخذ اسرته
واخد عدد كبير من افراد عائلتها ونضمن
لمناطق السيطره لتحت يدها حركه الشباب
الصوماليه هل هذا صحيح
كم عدد المجموعه اللي معاه لا يوجد هناك
عدد لكنه هو ذكر انه هو وعائلته وان
هاجروا الى جنوب الصومال حيث تصادم الحركه
ربما هو باقتلاعه بانه يهاجر من منطقه
تستولي عليه الكفار والمشركون يعني هذا
هذه فكره خطيره وهي الفكره التي ادت الى
استباحه الدماء المسلمين في جنوب الصومال
في كذلك في المعادله اخرى وبالتالي هو
اقتناعه بانه يهاجر وينتقل من من من من
هرجيسا الى جنود الصومال الى منطقه الجبل
الان بمعنى انه ربا وباريس طقوسا اخرى
بانه يهاجر من من من من مكه الى المدينه
هذه فكره خاطئه وفهم ينبغي ان يعني هل
ممكن ان هو همم هل ممكن هو انه لديه الان
مجموعه خاصه في همم يديرها ينظمها
تبع يعني وتتبع لحركه الشباب لكن هو يسيطر
عليها
حركه الشباب لكن هذه مجموعه يعني يعني
تنقاد لي ادم الصومالي بالدرجه الاولى
في الحركه ومن شيوخها ودعتها وعلمائها
يقولون قبل فتره هناك مؤتمر في جبل الوسطى
همم قالوا ان العلماء والدعاء المؤيدين
لحركه عقبوا فيها المؤتمر وبيعلم فيها وهو
كان من ضمن تلك المجموعه
ولكنه ليس له انصار وليس له همم انصارا
ولكنه يقال بعض الناس يقولون همم قد يستحق
في المستقبل من الشخصيات ربما مؤثره خاصه
في نشر الافكار وفي تسجيل المحاضرات وفي
ايضا كذلك همم
ان صار الحركه في مواصلات القتال ولكنه
همم كشخص ليس له فريق وليس له اعصار
وهذا هي من ضمن ادبيات الحركه انها لا
تسمح ان يكون هناك شخص له انصاره مرتبطين
به ولكن الشخص الذي يتحكم في مسار في
مفاصل حركته هو امير لحركه الذي هو يدير
شؤونها حاليا لكن في حركه الشباب
الصوماليه كان همم عده مرات في تاريخ
الحركه ان يكون هناك انشقاق من داخلها
وهمم وباخذ معه مثلا الشخصيه البارزه في
هذه الحركه تكون نائب او ضمن القياده
العامه للحركه فتاخذ معها 500 400 شخص
شفنا احنا كان في شخصيه حتى تولد منصب
رسمي في الصومال
فاتني اسمها كان هو قيادي همم بارز جدا في
حركه الشباب الصوماليه تولى منصب وزير
الشؤون الدينيه اتوقع في عام 2018
الحركه لم تصل من الانشقاقات وتصدعات منذ
تاسيسها فاا نايب امير الحركه انشق عن
حركه عام 2009 وهو الان رئيس ولايه جبل
الان في في الصومال وهو متحالف مع الحكومه
الصوماليه كان هناك ايضا في عام 2013
الدينيه في الحكومه الحاليه مختاره ايضا
عن الحركه وكذلك هناك اخرون انشقوا من
حركه
همم مستمر حتى الان ولكنه همم يعود الى ما
يعود الى التباين في استخدام الوسائل همم
القاتل التدميريه فالحركه تستخدم وسائل
الى همم تدميليه وهي تفجيرها
همم الاماكن المزدحمه وكذلك
اضافه الى ان اهداف الحركه ليس واضحه هل
هي حركه صوماليه ولا حركه عالميه اصبحت
حركه عالميه همم لا تؤمن بالدوله
الصوماليه ايضا هي لا تقود همم لا غير
مستعد ان تتفاوض مع الحكومه الصوماليه على
صير مثال على عام 2014 كان هناك مجموعه
داخل الحركه ربما تؤمن ان تتحاور مع
الحكومه همم الصوماليه ولكن امير الحركه
الصادق يعبي جدا هو الذي قضى عليها
واعدمهم كلهم وبالتالي انا شعارات هذه همم
مستمره وهي مستقبضه باهداف بتبين لاهدافي
والبرامج والمشاريع داخل الحركه طب السيد
تجيب انا يعني قبل ما ننتقل في شرق الثاني
من حديثنا عن حركه الشباب الصوماليه
واقعها اليوم همم بالنسبه لادم الصومالي
همم هل تعتقد ان هذا الاحتفاء الكبير الذي
شهدته مواقع حاصل اجتماعي واصبح اسمه يعني
ضمن همم
في خانات اللي في همم
محركات البحث في جوجل همم فهل تعتقد بانه
قد يكون هو امير حركه الشباب الصوماليه
همم ان يتولى مثلا او يكون نائب امير
الحركه يعني يتولى منصب قيادي بارز ربما
هذا همم ربما هذا همم من الامور او من
الاسباب التي ادت الى مصر اسمي
وبرامجه في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لانه ربنا يعاني من مشاكل صحيه كما يقال
لكن عموما همم الشخص هو اا اذا كان اذا
كان همم الامير همم القادم الامير الحالي
ربما هو الذي اختار كتابه يكتب كتابه
الامير القادم ولكن عموما هذا الشخص سيصبح
من الشخصيات البارزه
في المستقبل همم سواء كان في الطرح والفكر
او كذلك في الاداره ولكنه حتى الان لم يصل
اليه اي منصب اداري لكن ربما سيكون ايضا
من الشخصيات المحركه التي تساهم في في
مواصله مشروع وبرامج الحركه الذي يتعارض
مع اسس وقواعد الشعب الصومالي حكومه جيت
لي هو يعني عنده مرض صحي عند مشاكل صحيه
وهو الذي قال ذلك عندما اعرض نفسه وقدم
خطبه في في في
عدم وصوله الى جنوب الصومال في مارس
الماضي هو الذي تحدث عن انه مريض وانه
يعاني من مشاكل في المعده وفي البطن ربما
قالت تعرض الى الى عمليات تعذيب وما الى
ذلك لكن لن نعرض بصوره ولكنه تحدث عنه
وانه كان عنده مشكله كبيره في الباطن على
هذا الاساس همم او في الظهر وعلى هذا
الاساس ربما قد يكون هذا استعطافا من
الحركه وانه تلقى الصنوفا من التعليم
ترحيبه ربما كان هذا في معنى ذلك
طبعا هي دائما
عناصر التنظيمات التاليه هذه الدريه بانهم
تعرضوا للتعذيب والاضطهاد في في في السجون
وماذا ذلك همم ابي همم ابغى اسالك استاذي
بالنسبه لعن واقع حركه الشباب الصوماليه
اليوم وطبعا نحن نعرف انها احد اقوى اذرع
تنظيم القاعده
واهمها في اييي في القاره الافريقيه
وكان في سفير الامريكي في في الصومال كان
ذكر على ان حركه الشباب الصوماليه عدد
عناصرها ما يقارب 7,000 شخص همم فهل هذا
دقيق هل الى هذه الدرجه هذه الحركه باتت
اليوم بهذا القوه
مساله العدد هي مجرد تخمين ولكن همم خليني
احكي لك هذه القصه لان الحركه منذ عرفي
وسته الى اليوم هي موجوده في جنوب الصومال
خاصه منذ 2008 بعد المناطق الاستراتيجيه
همم في الصومال علما بان الشعب الصومالي
بنسبه
57% يقيمون في الالياف والبوادي والحركه
تتحكم في تلك المناطقيه
مع ذكر الرئيس الشيخ محمود وبالتالي فان
الحديث عن عائض الحركه وانها خمسه او سته
او سبعه هذه الموجبه تخميم وانا اعتقد
انها عددها يعكر من ذلك ولكن هي مرتبط ب
7,000 نعم بالالاف لان هناك شيوخ همم
قبائل لهم هناك مراكز تدريب هناك ايضا على
مستمر وبالتالي فالعدد ليس بهذه بهذا
يقولون ولكن بصوره عامه عن حركه حاليا همم
تتعرض
لحامله عسكريه همم منذ قرص الماضي وهي
تذهب بعض المناطق الاستراتيجيه همم
الواقعه وسط وجروب الصومال
للمتخصص في الشؤون الامنيه بان حركه
الشباب الصوماليه تجمع في الشهر الواحد 15
مليون دولار وذكر بان العوائد السنويه
لحركه الشباب الصوماليه اعلى من عوائد
الدوله
همم ويعني فحتى ان مصاريف تشغيل الحركه
تكون ما هي بهذا الضخامه اللي من ارادتها
الماليه
فكيف تشوف الموضوع من يعني من فين تجيبهم
هذه الاموال الطائله في الصومال وكانها
يعني دوله داخل دوله يعني
الحركه هي كمان ذكرته لك سابقا ان هي همم
مكتمل الاركان همم ولو همم قواعده واخصصه
وكذلك همم مستعدله الماليه وبالتالي فان
حركه منذ
الحركه تمكنت من جمع ضرائب همم من التجاره
الصوماليين سواء كانوا همم مختلفه التجاره
الصومالي يعني كانوا في المدن او في او في
الارياف سواء كانوا مزارعين سواء كانوا
همم همم اصحاب مصانع وفنادق وشركات اسوان
التجاري الذين لهم شركات ضخمه وكذلك شركات
الاتصال وما ذلك الحركه هي تجمع الضرائب
على مثل ما تجمع الحكومه الضرائب وبالتالي
الحركه وكل من لم ااه يدفع ضريبه سيتم
استدافه استهداف محلات التجاريه همم على
طريق ما حصل في همم في فندق الحياه همم
يعني قبل شهرين فالحركه
والتخويف تجمع تلك الاموال اعطال الكبيره
التي ربما هي اكبر من الضرائب التي تجمعها
الحكومه السيد عبد الرحمن هل استهدافهم
لفندق الحياه بسبب انها طلبت ااا اموال من
الرجال الاعمال او المالكي او المستثمرين
في الفندق اما اللي كانت لها اهداف اخرى
لهذا فكانا من ضمن الهدف مالي اصفر
معلومات المتوفره طبعا
لكن الهدف الرئيسي كان على همم حصول اموال
الحركه رفعت سقف همم على اسعار الفندق
ونشرها بقى ذلك تم استدافها وتدمير الفندق
على فكره ابيه وبالتالي على الحركه
باستخدامها باستخدامها تهريب الترهيب
باستخدامها بالتدميرها
التاجر الصومالي يكون متبورا النت فعل
امواله حمايه نفسه وامواله
في بعض المراقبين وايضا المتخصصين وايضا
يعني المسؤولين غربيين بيتحدث بان في داخل
الصومال ان اعضاء الحكومه اساتذه الجامعات
وشطاء المجتمع المدني صحفيين همم بيخشون
حركه الشباب الصوماليه همم يعني
مجرد ان تاتيهم التهديدات همم مثلا حتى
رجال الدين وحتى الدعاء في الجوامع بانهم
يعني اما ان يلتزموا بما تملي تمليه عليهم
او انه يتم اغتيالهم اا حتى ان الكثير من
رجال الاعمال يدفع ثروات لحركه الشباب
والزكاه اللي همم دخلهم مالي همم فين
سيطره الدوله
يعني في في في المدن الصوماليه خاصه احنا
اذا تسمح لي انه في 2010 كان خرج التنظيم
همم استطاعت الدوله ان تخرج التنظيم خارج
مقادي لكنها همم من سنوات رجعت رجعت تنظيم
وبقوه في عدد من المدن الصوماليه ومنها
مقاديشهم اختي همم المعركه او الحروب
المستمره في الصومال اللي هي حروب بين
الدوله الصوماليه وبين حركه الشباب وحركه
الشباب كمان اذا كانت السابقه هي نفسها
دوله في داخل دوله يلا طالما تتحكم بعد
المناطق السياده في الصومال فهي ايضا
وتدير انشرها وتتعامل مع الشعب الصومالي
كذلك اذا فالحرب همم يدوروا بين الشعب
يعني الحكومه تريد ان تصدر الشعب وتدير
الشعب والحركات كذلك وبالتالي همم كل شخص
يتعامل مع الحكومه الصوماليه هو المستهدفه
من قبل حركه الشباب سواء كان داعيا وعالما
سواء كانت تاجرا سواء كان اي شيء يعني سمي
شيء سواء كان همم اكاديميا لو انه له مركز
همم طالما انه مقتنع بفكره الدوري
الصوماليه مقتنع بالسلامي مقتنع بالتعايش
السلمي مقتنع بالدوله الصوماليه فهو
مستهدف من من قبل الحركه فهذا هذا شيء
طبيعي ومعروف لدى الشعب الصومالي وقبل
اسبوعين تقريبا قتل داعيا وعالما كبيرا في
في موضوع الشعوب بسبب انه همم تحدثت في
خطبه الجمعه ااه تحدث عن حرمه دماء
المسلمين وان همم
التفسير الذي وقع في اصابه في 29 في الشهر
الماضي كان كان محرما ولا يجوز ذلك فبعد
يوم تم اغتياله من قبل الحركه وعلى هذا
الاساس هذه المساله هي مساله مرتبطه
بالوجود همم بالوجود والاثبات وان كل ما
يتعامل مع الحكومه من قبل الحركه ولكن على
الحكومه ان تقوم بدورها وتحمي وتربي حمايه
للشعب الصومالي وكل ما يقف معها هل قادرها
الحكومه على مواجهه حركه الشباب الصوماليه
في مثل هذا الوضع مثل يعني احنا امس كانت
في هجمات شديده كانت في العاصمه مقاديشو
وقع همم انفجار بقرب من مقر همم الرئاسه
الصوماليه همم خلينا نقسم المواجهه الى
عيد الى عده
جبهات الجبهه المعارك والقتال هو مستمر
والحكومه همم تواصل الحمله العسكريه على
مناطق الحركه قبل يومين الحركه الحكومه
اعلنت مقتل 100 من مقاتله حركه الشباب في
وسط الصومال القتال المستمر الى الجانبين
هذه همم ناحيه لكن الناحيه اخرى المعركه
الاقتصاديه هذه اذا الحكومه لم تتمكن حتى
الان وضعي استراتيجيه واضحه لضبط
الاقتصادي ولضب الصادرات والضبطي والحمايه
وتوفير لحمايه لتجاره الصوماليين هذه
الحكومه لم تستطيع في ذلك في ما يتعلق
بالمجال التعليم
ومراجعه المناهج الدراسيه في ما يتعلق
بالمعادل الفكريه وهي تجيش وتعبئه العلماء
والدعاءات لمواجهه همم الحركه فكريه بعيدا
عن الحكومه ربما ايضا في في دورها ان تبدا
عموما همم الحكومه هناك مشاكل همم
متزامنه مشاكل متراكمه همم منذ يعني
استمرت لمده 15 15 عاما والحكومه عليها ان
تكسب عقول وقلوب الصوماليين وكذلك بطون
الصوالين لابد ان تقدم الحكومه خدمات الى
الشعب الصومالي خدمات الصحيه وتعليميه
وحفل الاداره وما الى ذلك ومحاربه والجهل
وكل ذلك صحيح
همم طبعا هي هذه همم يعني ابجديات العمل
لاعاده لعدم استقطاب الحركات الراديكانيه
للشباب همم
داخل صفوفها همم ولكن الواقع شيء اخر
الواقع انه هناك همم يبدو ان هناك عجز
كبير جدا على اعاده السيطره على همم
الكثير يعني تان الايرادات الموانئ
البحريه اصبحت الحركه الشباب تستطيع ان
تحصل على معلومات للبواخر والشاحنات التي
تاتي الى الميناء عبر اشخاص يشربوا كافه
البيانات هذه حتى تسريب ارقام
المواطنين الصوماليين وايضا رجال الاعمال
يعني فتواصل معهم مباشره لتهددهم اما بدفع
او بالقتل همم المواطن البسيط ما يقدر
نايبني بيتها الين حتى يدفع لحركه الشباب
الصوماليه
للبناء ونقل المواد البناء ابغى في ظلها
الوضع استاذ عبد الرحمن انتقل نتحدث موقع
تنظيم القاعده اليوم في ظل هذا المشهد
هناك من يرى بان تنظيم القاعده وايضا فلول
او همم تنظيم داعش من ليبيا من سوريا من
العراق
من كل المناطق اللي كانت شهيدات في فتره
ما يعرف بالربيع العربي من اضطرابات انها
يعني
عادات لتستقر من جديد في في مناطق حركه
الشباب الصوماليه وتنشط وهناك ايضا من يرى
بان
النشاط الحركه الشباب الصوماليه هي
الرسائل من تنظيم القاعده همم بالذات بعد
مقتل ايمن الظواهري فهل تتفق مع هذا همم
بما يخص في الصلاه فان حركه الشباب هي
ربما او يعتبر الذراع اقوى ذراع عليه
تنظيم بالقاعده في العالم وليس همم اوسط
او في اسيا او حتى في افريقيا بل هو في
العالم همم باعتبار ان الحركه لديها مساج
الى تمويل الماليه والحركه لديها خبره
فيما يتعلق بمواصله لها على ناجي التنميه
القاعده همم وبالتالي
مع ايضا ال- التنظيم القاعده ربما ايضا هو
طبعا تعرضا لانكساتا وتراجع و و و و معركه
مستمره ضده ولكنه ربما عندما يلتفت الى
الصومال والمنطقه القرن الافريقي يرى ان
نهجه تميم القاعده وبرامجها ومشاريعها
مستمره بل الحركه هي بمثابه الدوله شبه
دوله تدير يعني شؤون ااه مجتمع وشؤون
المناطق الكبيره جدا همم الحركه ليست يعني
مثل المناطق اخرى مثل في اليمن وفي شمال
افريقيا اخرى بل هي لديها حركه وتتحرك
وتديه وتستر كل ما تريده وبالتالي ربما
هناك بعض كذلك دراسات التي تشير الى حالنا
الى ان حركه الشباب هي من ضمن الروافد
الاساسيه لتنظيم القاعده حيث تحصل على
القاعده ان التدريب القاعده نفسها يحصل
دعمه المال احيانا من حركه الشباب لان ما
همم حركه تحصر 15 مليون دولار شهريا عسم
ذكر المركز الذي ذكرته هي قادره على
تسديري افكارها في شرق افريقيا حتى
وبالتالي همم التهديد قد يكون قادما يعني
الحركه تهدد اثيوبيا وتشوف تحديدا لكينيا
وكذلك في الشرق افريقيا في هولندا وعلى
هذا الاساس الحركه لم تعود حركه المحليه
في الصومال اصبحت حركه مخلصه لتنظيم
القاعده اخدت دروسها كما هي وتنفذها
وتطبقها على ارض الواقعه هل ممكن اليوم
بعد ما خاصه همم بعد الاتفاق السياسي ما
بين حركه الطالبان
وبين الولايات المتحده والمجتمع الدولي
همم بان تصبح الصومال هي المرفى لتنظيم
القاعده ولباقي الحركات المسلحه الاصوليه
يدور خاصه خلال العشر الاخيره يدور
هل يمكن ان تصبح حركه الشباب مثل حركه
الطالبان هل يمكن الان تغير نهجها السابق
وتنفصل عن تقديم القاعده هل يمكن ان تعتنق
وتؤمن بجغرافيه الدوله الصوماليه وبدستور
الصومالي
وكذلك استعدادها ان تشارك الحكم في
الصومال يعني كل هذه الاسئله همم مطروحه
في الساحه الصوماليه ولكن انا في اعتقادي
وما اشاهدته حاليا وكذلك الحركه الحركه
همم لم تعد كما كانت لم تعد مثل حركه
طالبان بل هي هي الحركه من اهدافها من
اهدافها الاساسيه استغلال مدافع الاساسيه
كذلك ان ترفض النظم الدوليه
وكذلك الشرعيه الدوليه من اهدافها كذلك
عدم اعترافها الدوله العصريه على طريقه
الحاليه من الاتيه الشريعه على فهمها همم
وبالتالي وبالتالي من هذه الناحيه من
ناحيه اخرى ايضا ربما همم الصومال قد يصبح
دائما ساحه مفتوحه لمن ياتي من الخارج
سواء كانه من افغانستان سواء كانوا من من
بلد اخر ولكن دعني اقول لك شيء الصومال
لبلد المفتوح ليست له جبال وليست له اوديه
اا يختبئ فيها وكل من ياتي من الاجانب
الذين اتوا من الاجانب الى الصومال كلهم
تم اغتيالهم يعني اما بقاله جويه واما شيء
اخر وبالتالي فمن السهل جدا اصطياد
المقاتل الاجنبي الذي ياتي من الخارج الى
الصماء
يكون سهلا ليس مثل بعض وبالتالي همم
علاقه بين الصومال وبين اليمن العلاقات
في اليمن حلاقته استراتيجيه والمستمره
وعلى هذا الاساس ربما
حتكون هناك تنسيقا وتعاونا ودعمنا متبادلا
العالميه نسوان كانت هتعمل عسكريه او دعما
ماليا لاستمرار الصمود والقتال في كل
الجبهات بالنسبه في السنتين الاخيره هذه
هل هناك معلومات على مثلا من ضمن من تم
القاء القبض عليهم او من استهدفتهم
الغارات الجويه للتحالف الولايات المتحده
او الدول الغربيه همم بانه مقتل مثلا
مقاتلين اجانب في صفوف حركه الشباب هل
هناك يعني برزات اسماء لعناصر غير صوماليه
ضمن حركه الشباب على اسماء البارزه
السابقه عن همم
كذلك اخرون همم هناك مصري وهناك من جزر
القمر وهناكينه هؤلاء هو كذلك سوداني
هؤلاء تم تصفيته همم قبل فتره يعني ولكن
همم وهذا وهذا هو الصعب الذي قلت لك سابقا
ان همم ان قيادات التنظيم القاعده على
جانب همم
ان لما لم تعد الصومال المعقل لهم ولا
معمل لهم همم خليني اعود لك حتى على كان
من ضمن الادبيات
السابقه في تسعنيات ان ينتقل اوصاهم بهذه
السلطانه ولكنه بعد الدراسه تبين له انه
لا يستطيع ان يقتني في الصومال وبالتالي
همم لا يوجد هناك حاليا شخص مهم يعني بهذه
الضخامه لكن ربما يكون هناك شخصا همم تم
همم ذكر اسمه في قبله اسبوعين تقريبا وهو
مضروب
نعم لكن عموما عموما
استاذ عبد الرحمن
من وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه هي مطلوبه
همم مطلوبه همم مضروبه يعني معرفه هو همم
مقابل اموال يعني ضمنه همم
وكذلك اخرون يعني لكن عموما همم هذه
اللائحه عليها اجنبيه
هي موجودين في في في لقائمه ولكن هؤلاء
ربما لا يشكرون
واحد يعمل في في المتفجرات وما الى ذلك
همم وفي تدريب المقاتلين الصوماليين ولكنه
همم
ربما هو يعني همم ليس من ضمن التشكيله
الاساسيه في بدايه الحركه هل
تعتقد او من وجهه نظرك ان النشاط او
العمليات الاخيره اللي همم نفذتها حركه
الشباب هي تاتي الرسائل للرد على مقتل
ايمن الظواهر خاصه ان حسابات همم
الاعلاميه لتنظيم القاعده كانت همم رحبت
في هذه التفجيرات وبركتها
بل ان ما تقوم به الحركه حاليا هو مرتبط
خطواتها العسكريه والامنيه وكذلك همم
اظهارها انها لا تزال حركه قويه همم تواجه
تواجه على حركه وتسنها جماعه على على عقل
الحكومه الصوماليه خاصه وان حركه وجاءت
فرصه في في الصلوات الخمسه الماضيه
وبالتالي هي الان تريد ان ترسل رساله الى
الحكومه الجديده ان ان الحركه لازاله
متماسك وقويه وكذلك الحركه شالت حاولت الى
اثيوبيا في شهر يوليو الماضي نفذت عمليات
خارج ايضا ارض الصومال
العمليات الحركه هي همم منحصنه في جنوب
الصماء
تقريبا من اسبوعين او من شهر
كان هناك عمليه
حمله حاولت الحركه عند الصلاه الاله
اثيوبيا اييه في شهر يوليو الماضي مستخدمه
بدعه الاف من من مقاتلها حوالي 1000
وزياده ولكن القوات القوات الصوماليه في
الاقليم الصوماليا
ولكن كانت هذه الرساله واضحه بان حركه
تريد ان تنتقل وتتمدد الى اثيوبيا كذلك
حيث تشكل المسلمين
كانت تريد ان تنشا السفاره
في السياقه التنافس ما بين تنظيم القاعده
همم
حركه الشباب الموالي الى القاعده بين مع
ترنيمه
وكذلك مختفي في
كيف حضور تنظيم داعش في الصومال حضور
تنظيم داعش في الصومال هو حضور خافت وحضور
ضعيف يعني مختفي جدا لان همم لان اصلا هو
لم يجد فرصه لكي ينتشرك الجنوب الصومال
همم
لثلاث عوامل اساسيه الاعمال الاول لمواجهه
الحركه لهذا التنظيم وكذلك العامل الثاني
همم
الاجهزه الامنيه الصوماليه شبكه التدريب
القاعده
اضافه الى ان همم الشعب الصناعي لا لا غير
مستعد عن ان يتقبل بروز تنظيم اخر من غير
همم مثل
وبالتالي لم يعد طريق داعش همم ظاهرا
ومتمر لسانه ومتحركه
وتراجعه وهو السيد الموقف طب اسمح لي
يعني بهذا السؤال انا هناك امس انا بعد ما
وقع التفجير في مقادييشو مساء يوم امس في
حسابات الراديكاليه والجهاديه كانت بدات
تتفائل بقرب همم استيلاء حركه الشباب
الصوماليه على الحكم في الصومال وتاسيس
همم الدوله الاسلاميه التي هي طبعا يعني
هذا يعني اولى همم اول مبادئ التي هي تسعى
اليها وطبعا هي تعتبر الدوله الاسلاميه
بالنسبه لها تشمل من اجزاء من اثيوبيا
وكينيا والصومال جيبوتي هل تعتقد ان في ظل
نشاط وهذه الايرادات الماليه لحركه الشباب
الصوماليه همم هناك تهديد على الحكومه
نفسها وانت تستولي على الحكم مثل ما فعل
طالبه نعم نعم هناك تهديد على الحكومه
وتهديد على كينيا وترديد على اثيوبيه كذلك
لديها عائدات ومساجد اموال ضخمه كبيره
وبالتالي فهي تستخدم تلك الاموال لتجنيد
الشباب القرن الافريقي الذين يعانون من
الفقر يعانون من التهميش احيانا وبالتالي
فالحركه لان هي تشكل تهديد اصلا هي تشكل
تهديدا للصومال لمنطقه الافريقي ولكن
ان تنتقل الى اثيوبيا هكذا ولايه وتنتقل
الى هكذا يصرف عليها ولكنها
ستحاول ان همم تتواجد وتمركز في الصومال
وربما ايضا همم بعد ذلك تعد بعض الشبكات
وترسلها الى خارج الصومال طبعا احنا
بنتكلم حركه الشباب احنا نتكلم عن تنظيم
القاعده همم وهناك بعض من يرى بان ان ان
تنظيم داعش كان اعلن عن خلافه الاسلاميه
من الموصل
اه والرقه ان تنظيم القاعده يسعى الى
اعلان دولته الاسلاميه من الصومال ويبدا
ينشئ ولايات اسلاميه في الدول الافريقيه
المجاوره الحدوديه للصومال اسمح لي اختم
في هذا السؤال همم الشيخ التيك توك همم
المشهور ادم الصومالي هل يعني متزوج لديه
اطفال ابناء ايش وضع اسرتهم فيما يتعلق ب-
همم ادم همم هو طبعا ابو يعني هو كمان له
وهو متزوج وله اولاد وعائلته واسرته حاليا
يقيمون يعيشون بين يظهر الحركه ويعشوره في
مناطق في جنوب الصومال اعتقد في مناطق همم
وجبل الوسطى طب هل هل لديك معلومه سيده هو
كان متزوج من اكثر من سيده عدد ابناءك
معلوماتي يعني هل لديك ليس له علم او عليه
شخصيه تفصيليه ولكنه هو وعائلته همم انتقل
منرجيسه الى الى الى الى الى الى المناطق
الخادعه لحركه السابقه مع ذكر هو نفسه
ولكن الشخصيه ليست كما يروج عنه انه ليس
شخصيه اسطوريه لم يعد لم يعد شخصيه
الاسطوريه وليس له تاريخ ونضال حافي في
ساحات القتال في الصومال وبالتالي هو فقط
كان يمارس الخطابه ويمارس الدعوه ويكون
كان راشدا للحركه فقد هذا كان دوره فقط
ولكن همم
رساله الى علماء الصومال همم
ما تتفق معي ان همم يعني الضغط
لمقاطع لمقطعه يعني ثواني وايضا بلغات
باللغه العربيه واللغه الانجليزيه ان هناك
منظومه هي خلف هذا الترويش وليس فقط انها
مجموعه شباب هو منتمين او محبين او مؤيدين
للجماعات الراديكاليه مسلحه في حاله في
حاله الشيخ وغيره اييه
اعتقد ان حركه الشباب تملك دراء عن
اعلاميه يدير كل هذه الانشطه ويستخدم
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ويعد بعد البرامج وينشرها في سوره الواقعه
وهذه وهذا المشروع وهذه الشبكه مرتبطه
بالشركات العالميه من القاعده وبالتالي
هذا التوجه ربما ياتي ايضا في اطار تسويق
افكار لحركتي وانها مستعده
لمراسات المشروعيه
على الحكم في الصمال ايوه
يعطيك الف عافيه وشكرا جزيلا لك معنا
واسمح لي اني اختم حلقتنا همم الله يسلمك
لطالما اتقنت جماعه الاسلام السياسي بشقها
السياسي والمسلسل صنا اساطرها كشفت تيك
توك وشيخ اليوتيوب وشيخ المنابر لكنها
شخصيات ليست فقط نمر من وراء
صنعتها ماسي تربويه ومساوئ ثقافيه
وانحرافات فكريه واخفاقات سياسيه هذا
جماعات وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]